in Brussels refugees awaiting asylum
rulings get food and shelter their
stories of the war or oppression they
fled a well documented so to their long
journeys to Europe less so is what
happens next pathways to integration in
their new home not least finding work we
see often very talented people people
who come here and they tell you that
they're a doctor a lawyer they fill in
the gap where there is people needed and
they have the expertise they have the
experience the capabilities without
employment so high in Europe especially
among the young delivering jobs to
refugees is a touchy subject in each
member state we need some specific
programs to integrate the refugees so
that these people are quickly moved from
being someone some people that are a
humanitarian cause they need the money
they need support to be instead
productive elements paying taxes
producing economy in Parliament's
employment committee mr. ban fa is
pushing for new ways to be fine to
support refugees efforts to find work
he's got wide support across the groups
we cannot just think that the Member
States alone can solve the problem we
need to assist them we need to be close
to them and support them also
financially the report which if passed
won't be legally binding is expected to
go to the full plenary before the summer